men called me the Spyder long before I
came to Westeros as a young thief in
Pentos I seem to have eight hands
each dipped into a stranger's pocket but
the other thieves didn't appreciate my
skill and they had size and strength
that I couldn't match when they
discovered why I was beaten and told
that a unified as until on in the
streets but in the brothels as any
slaver would know I managed to escape
them and took to sleeping in the sores
by day and prowling the rooftops by
night barely one step ahead of
starvation much less slavery then I met
Illyrio mopatis he was a Brava who lived
by his sword but his mind was sharper
than his blade I proposed an arrangement
I would spy on lesser thieves and steal
their takings Illyria would offer help
to the thieves victims promising to
recover their valuables for a fee soon
every honest man knew to come to Illyria
was the city's cut purses sought me half
to sell me what they had stolen and the
other half to slit my throat sadly for
their malaria needed my throat more than
he needed theirs most thieves like most
men are fools who think no further than
turning a Knights plunder into wine
luckily as the other thieves had
reminded me I was not a man
nor where those are hired with the gold
we earned I chose the smallest off the
boys and girls the ones who were as
quick and quiet as me and told them to
climb walls and slip down chimneys my
little birds left the shiny treatments
for common thieves and instead still
letters ledges and charts secrets are
worth far more than silver or sapphires
later I taught my little birds to read
the letters themselves and leave them
where they lay Center one would know of
our intrusion
Illyrio and I grew so rich that Illyria
where'd a princess of Pentos whilst
whispers of my talents reached the ears
of a very anxious King across the Narrow
Sea who did not trust his son nor his
wife nor his hand nor should he have as
I told him once I arrived and raised
more little birds they thought it the
most amazing game to discover all the
secret tunnels through the Red Keep and
listen to all the whispered secrets from
within the castle walls I often wonder
what became of my little birds once I
left King's Landing
most likely they returned to flea bottom
or worse grew up one day I'll hear their
song again until then well the world
never lacks for orphans little bird sing
in the West and little birds sing in the
East and a harpy flies into a spider's
web